[موسيقى]
يلا هلا شويه ونصير عندكم ماشي
شو
طيب ماشي بلشت بالعشره يلا ان شاء الله
[تصفيق]
دبر لنا شيء حرام مشان فيها
محمود يلا يلا
الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على السلامه حمد لله على
السلامه
في حد عندك جوه عمو اخواتي بس ميتين امي
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدي العربيه نستمر في
هذه التغطيه لهذه الفاجعه التي حلت على
السوريين والاتراك جراء الزلزال الذي ضرب
البلدين ففي اليوم الثالث لم يتغير ولم
يفرق الواقع الاليم سوى بوتيره ارتفاع عدد
الضحايا فالنعوش تعبر جانبي حدود الزلزال
ولحظات ترافقها تارى شعور بالالم والعجز
على فقدان مدنيين وتاره اخرى بفرحه مؤقته
يرافقها شعور بانجاز بعد انقاذ روح كانت
عالقه لساعات طويله حتى جاءها الفرج
وبينما تغوص فرق الانقاذ لمزيد من الانقاذ
ارتفعت حصيله القتلى في تركيا الى
9,057 قتيلا واصابه نحو 53,000 بينما على
الجانب الاخر من الحدود ومن حدود الزلزال
وهي البقعه السوريه من الجغرافيا هناك حيث
فقد اكثر من ثلاثه الاف
و330 شخص فقدوا منازلهم نتيجه
لتضرر مناطق وارواحهم ايضا
دمار لم يفرق بين انسان واخر اطفالهم
وعائلاتهم تحت الانقاذ وكلهم يعدون
الدقائق لبل الثواني علل النفس يتماسك
لحين وصول المنقذين لكن حتى الكوارث
الطبيعيه في سوريا تخضع للتقسيمات
الجغرافيه التي تفرض واقعا يحدد المساعدات
وكيفيه توزيعها الزلازل
ضربت جزءا معقدا من الخريطه السوريه اي
الشمال الغربي منها السبب مشاهدينا ان
السيطره الاداريه والعسكريه في هذه
المناطق تتنازعها جهات عده فمدينه حلب
مثلا تقع تحت سيطره النظام فيما يقع ريفها
بيد فصائل مدعومه من تركيا كما نشاهد هنا
اما ادلب فتسيطر عليها جبهه تحرير الشام
او ما كانت تعرف سابقا بجبهه النصره دول
عده التقديم المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه
لكن المعابر المتعدده التي تربط بين
الشمال السوري والجنوب التركي مغلقه وتشمل
المعابر باب الهوى وباب السلامه والراعي
وجرابلس الواقعه تحت سيطره الفصائل التي
تدعمها تركيا ومعبر كسب الواقع كسب تحت
سيطره قوات النظام واغلقته تركيا بشكل
كامل عام 2014
معابر مرشد بنار وتل ابيض وراس العين
ونصيبين خاضعه لسيطره القوات الكرديه كما
نشاهد هنا يعد معبر باب الهوى حاليا
الشريان الوحيد الذي يغذي المحتاجين
بالمنطقه غير ان جهات اغاثيه اكدت انه
مغلق منذ صباح الاثنين بسبب اعطال في
الطرف التركي لكنها اكدت بالوقت نفسه ان
عمليه نقل المساعدات من تركيا الى سوريا
يمكن اتمامها من معبر باب السلامه في ريف
حلب ومعابر جرابلس والراعي علما بان
الاخير يقع بريف حلب الشمالي مقابل المعبر
الحدوديه التركيه جوباد باي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من غازي عنتاب ينضم الينا مفرد
العربيه غسان ابو اللوز معنا منها تاي
موفد العربيه ايضا عمار الهندي غسان سابدا
معك وسنركز يعني بهذه التغطيه على نقطه
اساسيه وهو موضوع ان الناجين الاحياء يعني
عاده ما يتم انتشار بين ثلاثه ايام واسبوع
الذي يحصل هناك حتى الساعه هل يمكن القول
اننا ما زلنا مزال يتم انقاذ ناجين احياء
ام ان معظمهم هم متوفين
يعني الليالي مع مرور تقريبا ثلاث ايام
على الزلزال ووجود عالقين تحت الانقاذ
تتضاءل
فرص في وجود ناجين لكن تبقى الامال معقوده
حتى هذه اللحظه على وجود ناجين تحت
الانقاذ ولذلك الاعمال ما زالت متواصله
ومستمره حتى الساعه وحتى اللحظه ويواصلون
الليل بالنهار في عمليات الانقاذ في
محاوله منهم
للوصول الى هؤلاء العالقين تحت الانقاذ
فرق الانقاذ منتشره في كل المناطق
التعزيزات تصل اولا باول وتستمر في العمل
بمختلف الاليات الممكنه والموجوده
والمتوفره
لمحاوله انقاذ العالقين تحت الانقاض كما
تشاهدين خلفي نحن في هذه البلده بلده
الاصلاحيه ما زالت الاعمال متواصله في هذا
المبنى كما تشاهدين
يحاولون ازاله ما يمكن ازالته من الانقاذ
علمنا من بعض شهود العيان هنا ان هناك
عالقين ايضا تحت هذا المبنى لكن لا يعلمون
حتى هذه اللحظه ما هو مصير هؤلاء العالقين
ان كانوا على عقيد الحياه ام لا لكنهم ما
زالوا يعني معلقون بالامل على امل ان
يكونوا على قيد الحياه والعمليات ما زالت
مستمره في هذه البلده التي يعني تشهد
دمارا كبيرا وتضررا كبيرا وتعد اكثر
المناطق
تضررا في غازي عنتاب وما زال العمل متواصل
حتى هذه الساعه وفي مناطق اخرى في هذه
البلده نحن نتحدث عن 50% من المباني في
هذه البلده
غسلنا على كل حال سنعود اليك اسمح لي ان
انتقل الى الزميل عمار هندي عمار ايضا
بنفس النقطه
لو سمحت ابقي لنا الصوره مفتوحه عمار بنفس
النقطه يعني عاده بحسب المعايير الدوليه
للانقاذ يتم رصد مستوى الاكسجين او ما
يعرف بثاني اكسيد الكربون بالمباني التي
يعني سقطت اسره الزلزال لمعرفه اذا كان
هناك امل لوجود احياء هل يعني رفضتم مع
فرق الانقاذ هذه النقطه ما هو الوضع هناك
على ما يبدو فقدنا زميل عمار هندي غسان
نفس النقطه اذا كنت سمعت السؤال
تستخدم كل الاليات والتقنيات
الحديثه وغيرها وتقليديه في محاوله الوصول
الى هؤلاء العالقين او ان كانوا على قيد
الحياه ام لا كما يعني نتابع ونشاهد
تستخدم هذه التقنيات الحديثه مع فرق
الانقاذ التي تصل الى تركيا خصوصا
الاجنبيه منها وايضا هناك الكلاب المدربه
على يعني في البحث عن العالقين تحت
الانقاذ ولذلك هم لا يؤلون اي جهد في هذه
العمليه لهذه العمليات الواسعه والكبيره
في هذه الكارثه التي حلت على البلاد
لانقاذ العالقين تحت الانقاض وهم دائما
يواصلون هذا العمل على امل ان يكون هناك
ناجين وربما الانباء التي تتوالى من عده
مناطق عن انقاذ عالقين ما زالوا على قيد
الحياه
استخراجهم وارسالهم الى المستشفيات لتلقي
العلاج اللازم يبث الامل فيهم على مواصله
هذه الاعمال هذه الاعمال
ومواصله هذه الاعمال لانقاذ
العالقين تحت الانقاذ وان كانت الساعات
التي تمر هي ساعات حاسمه ومهمه جدا
وساعات يعني
ربما تكون قاسيه على الجميع خصوصا على
الاهالي الذين يترقبون هذه اللحظات بفارغ
الصبر وهم يعني على امل ان يكون هناك
انباء على امل ان يكون
مجددا الى الزميل عمار الهندي الذي عاد
معنا من هاتاي عمار يعني كنا نتحدث عن
نقطه اساسيه الان وهو السباق مع الوقت
يعني كل دقيقه كل ساعه تاخير ممكن ان تفقد
روح او اكثر بهذه عمليه بعمليه البحث هذا
يعني من ان الانسان ممكن ان يبقى على قيد
الحياه بدون ماء من ثلاث الى اسبوع هل تم
رصد حركه تحت هذا الدمار بالمكان الذي
تتواجد فيه
هذه النظريه ليال صحيحه جدا لانه اليوم
وبعد انقضت شابه ثلاثينيه تقريبا 65 ساعه
تحت الانقاض تم انتشالها وكانت بصحه جيده
وانا رايتها ويعني مستيقظه وحتى غير فاقده
للوعي هذا هذا صحيح وبالتالي اليوم عاد
الامل لانه في اكثر من مكان من محافظات
وبلدات تركيا تم انتشار الاشخاص من تحت
الانقاض اليوم يعني فجر الليله المقبله
سيكمل هذا الزلزال ثلاثه ايام وبالتالي
سندخل في المرحله الحرجه بعد ثلاثه ايام
اعمال
الانتشار او البحث عن المفقودين لا تزال
جاريه نحن وسط هاتاي كما تعلمين هذا
المبنى الذي اليوم كانت انتشلت منه شاب
على قيد الحياه هنا الان وفي هذه الصوره
التي يعني تشاهدين هم يبحثون او يعني
كانوا سمعوا صوتا لشخص يعتقد انه على قيد
الحياه وبالتالي اعمالهم توقفت من حيث
الاليات الثقيله وهم الان يعملون بشكل
بطيء جدا بحثا عن هذا الشخص او الصوت الذي
سمعوه يحفرون نفقا كما علمت للوصول الى
مكان هذا الصوت ايضا هذه المنطقه وحيث اقف
انا من ورائي السياسي التركي
معروف علي بابا جان ومتواجد هنا رئيس حزب
ديفا التركي المعارض جاء وزاره هذه
المنطقه والان يتحدث الى وسائل الاعلام
التركيه هذه العائلات على يمين الكاميرا
هذه اسر اشخاص مفقودين في هذا المبنى لم
يتحركوا من مكانهم وهم يعني سيبقوا هنا
حتى العثور ومعرفه مصير ابنائهم السؤال
الاكبر الذي الذي طرحتي صحيح وسليم انه هل
السباق مع الزمن هل سيخسر يعني الناجون
تحت الانقاض هذا السباق مع الزمن خصوصا
انه يعني الاجواء بارده جدا درجات الحراره
متدنيه ويعني الامر باداء يدخل في
عندما نتحدث عن ناجين اكثر نتحدث عن ظروف
طبيعيه يعني صحيه كامله ساعود اليكم
مراسلينا ابقوا معي لو سمحتوا مشاهدينا
سانتقل الان عبر سكايب من معبر باب الهوى
مازن علوش مدير العلاقات الاعلاميه
والمتحدث باسم اداره معبر باب الهواء
استاذ مازن يعني السؤال الاساسي الان هو
هل المعبر مفتوح بطريقه كامله
وطرقات صالحه لتمرير الامدادات من هناك كل
ما تحتاجه المنطقه الشماليه في سوريا
مساء الخير لكل الساده المشاهدين طبعا
معظم باب الهواء
من طرف السوري وطرف التركي لم يتاخر ابدا
بالزلزال ولا حسب الطرق المؤديه اليه لكن
لم تصل لدينا اي مساعدات اضافيه بكافه اي
جهه كانت منذ لحظه حدود الزلزال وحتى
تاريخ اليوم نحن في مساء اليوم الثالث
لهذه المقاسات التي ضربت الشعب السوري
وشعب التركي
استاذ مازن يعني كان هناك
تصريحات متضاربه حول يعني حول اتحدث عن
ظروف المعبر البعض يقول بان الطرقات هالكه
لا يمكن ان تمر عليها مساعدات اللازمه
التي تحتاج المنطقه الشماليه والبعض يقول
بان الطرقات صالحه ونحن بانتظار وصول
مساعدات اي من هاتين يعني من هذين
التصريحين هو الاصح
والاصح ان كل الطرقات صالحه
علما منذ اليوم الاول للزلزال وحتى تاريخ
اليوم نحن خلال ثلاثه ايام النظر مفتوح
فقط امام استقبال الجنازات السوريين
الذين لهم يقيمون لاجئين في الاراضي
التركيه فالثامين السوريين السيارات
تنقلهم من عده ولايات الى معبر باب الهواء
لايصال الى دفهم في المناطق المحرره شمال
سوريا وكيف
نفسها هي
صالحه للعبور السيارات النقل الموتى وليست
صالحه لعبود النقل المساعده مع العلم ان
الامم المتحده مستودعاتها الرئيسيه هي
تكون في مدينه الريحانيه
هذه المستودعات مليئه بالاصل قبل الزلزال
بيوم واحد كانت القوافل تدخل بشكل دوري
بعد قرار مجلس الامن الاخير بتمديد دخول
المساعده
نحن نشرنا بياناتي هو ان ابوابنا
المساعدات في اليوم التالي صباح البارحه
المتحده ان هنالك الطرق في المعبد من
الجانب التركي غير سالكه
نحن ايضا نشرنا اليوم انا مفتوحه قبل قليل
تصريح لوزير الخارجيه التركي ان الطرق
داخل سوريا غير سالبه لا اعلم
معبرين اضافيين مع سوريا هل هناك تنسيق
معكم على يعني على مداخل وتخوم الشمال
السوري واين ستكون هذه المعابر
نحن كل ما نعلمه ان معظم باب الهوى مفتوح
24 ساعه نحن نقوم باستقبال جثث اهلنا فقط
لا يوجد استقبال لاي مساعدات او اي فرق
تطوعيه او اضافيه او مشاكل ميدانيه او الى
ذلك
السيارات بامكانها الوصول الى المعبر بكل
سهوله من الجهتين الطرق لو سمحت اليوم
يعني الشمال السوري بمرحله سباق مع الوقت
خصوصا ان كل ساعه تاخير تكلف اكثر من 50
ضحيه هل ممكن ان تطلق صرخه للمجتمع الدولي
لكل من يتذرع بان الطرقات غير صالحه
والمعبر غير مفتوح وبالتالي لا يمكننا
ايصال المساعدات الى شمال سوريا واذا كان
هناك من عوائق من يعيق دخول هذه المساعدات
صراحه يعني كان هنالك جلسه قبل قليل بيني
وبين الجانب التركي
قالت تركي انهم
كل المعبرين سيكون جاهزين
لكن
لننتظر ولنرى هل هل من الصحيح ستلبي الامم
المتحده الاحتياجات السوريه المنكوبين ام
لا انا اؤكد لك انه حتى تاريخ اللحظه لا
يوجد اي دخول لاي مساعدات لدينا
الاف العوائل تشردت مئات العوائل ما زلت
تحت الانقاض خلال لمده 72 ساعه لدينا نقص
كبير في المعدات خاصه معدات التي تفتح
بازاله الامراض
كبيره من الجيوت شعبيه هنالك نظام كبير
جدا على المستوى الشعبي على مستوى الحكومي
على المستوى
العسكر نحن نتحدث كارثه على مستوى
الاستجابه الدوليه والانسانيه لكل
احتياجات بالمنطقه الشماليه اذا باختصار
لو سمحت اذا ما سالنا عن موضوع الاصابات
الاحتياجات الطبيه هناك ما الذي يحصل كيف
هي الصوره على الارض
الفتره قبل الزلزال كل الحاجات الحرجه
التي لا نستطيع علاجها كانت تخرج للعلاج
في مسافه التركيه
ما بتنزل الزلزال وحتى تاريخ اليوم توقف
ايضا خروج المرضى والحالات الشعبيه
البارده للعلاج التركيه فالاعتماد حاليا
هو فقط على كوادر الموجوده في المنطقه من
الاطباء والمشاكل الميدانيه وغيرها التي
هي لا تفتخر لكل شيء يعني
لو الله ثم التبرعات لتاتي من السوريين
المغتربين والتجار الموجودين في المناطق
هنا
والتمويل الحكومي
في من قبل حكومه انقاذ وغيرها
قمنا بماسات كبيره جدا يعني اما على مستوى
الدولي لم يصلنا اي شيء الدعم كله يصب اما
في صالح النظام نرى ان الدول الحديثه
للنظام تقوم بمجده
بالتيارات الاضافيه
في تركيا اما هنا اكثر من اربع ملايين من
مواطن منكوبين على مدار 12 عام من تاريخ
الثوره زاد عليهم هذه التمثال لا يوجد
لدينا اي اغاثه تردنا مع اننا نحن بامس
الحاجه لاي شيء يصل الى المنطقه اي شيء
كان بكلمه شكرا لك استاذ مازن علوش مدير
العلاقات الاعلاميه والمتحدث باسم اداره
معبر باب الهوى على هذه المداخله وعلى هذه
الصرخه الانسانيه التي اطلقتها من هناك
من غازي عنتاب ينضم الىنا موفد العربيه
غسان ابو اللوز اعود اليك غسان وايضا منها
طايق موفد العربيه عمار الهندي سابدا معك
غسان يعني اذا ما نقلنا المشاهدات الحيه
من هناك كيف هي الصوره كيف هو الواقع
خصوصا اننا دخلنا بساعات الليل وايضا درجه
الحراره اصبحت متدنيه كل هذه العوامل كيف
تؤثر على عمليات الالقاء
نعم بالفعل كما تشاهدون ليال عبر الصوره
الاليات ما زالت مستمره في هذا العمل هناك
درجات حراره متدنيه لكن لحسن الحظ لا يوجد
امطار ولا يوجد ثلوج كما في الايام
الماضيه
وهذا يسهل على فرق الانقاذ مواصله هذه
العمليات التحديات التي تواجه فرق الانقاذ
ايضا هي طريقه التعامل مع هذه الابنيه
وهذه المباني المنهاره يعني يتعاملون معها
بحرص ودقه شديدين تحسبا لاي انهيارات ممكن
ان تقع اثناء عمليات ازاله الانقاض وربما
تؤثر على العالقين تحت الانقاذ وهم لا وهم
لا يريدون ذلك بطبيعه الحال ايضا من ابرز
الصعوبات او المخاوف التي تواجه الفرق
الانقاذ والسلطات التركيه هو الهزات
الارتداديه نائب الرئيس الجمهوريه تحدث عن
800 هزه ارتداديه منذ الزلزال الذي ضرب
البلاد يوم الاثنين الماضي
وتحديدا قال 790 هزر ارتداديه وهي هذه
الهزات الارتداديه مقلقه جدا ومخيفه جدا
بالنسبه للسلطات التركيه لماذا لان هناك
مئات المباني تصدعت وهي ايله للسقوط ولا
تصلح حتى
للسكن حتى وان انتهت هذه الكارثه وتوقفت
الاهتزازات الارضيه
الارتداديه هذه البنايات لا تصلح للسكن
ابدا بتاتا وهم سيتعاملون مع هذه البنايات
وسيقومون ايضا
بهدم هذه البنايات لانها تشكل خطر كبير
وبالغ على حياه المدنيين بطبيعه الحال تم
اخلاء هذه المنطقه التي نقف فيها حاليا
وهي بلده الاصلاحيه في
غازي عنتاب من جميع سكانها وتم اخلاقهم
واجلائهم الى مخيمات والى مراكز ايواء
قريبه من هذا المكان وايضا هناك السلطات
تقول بانها ستقدم التسهيلات لمن يريدون
مغادره المناطق المنكوبه الى مناطق اخرى
وتقول الخطوط الجويه التركيه بانها ستقوم
يعني نقل 30,000 شخص الى مناطق اخرى
وبالتالي الاعمال ما زالت مستمره
اعمال الاغاثه ما زالت مستمره الفرق ما
زالت مستمره وتتعهد السلطات والرئاسه
التركيه بان يكون هناك عمل سريع
لازاله هذه الانقاض وبناء مساكن
للمتضررين وتعاهدت بانها لن تترك اي مواطن
وحيدا في ظل هذه الكارثه الانسانيه
الكبيره التي تمر بها البلاد
سنعود اليك طبعا ضمن هذه التغطيه لو سمحت
اترك لنا الكاميرا والصوره مفتوحه
شكرا لك
من القامش لمشاهدنا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش جمعه يعني السلطات
والمسؤولين الاكراد كانوا قد اعلنوا عنيا
لتقديم مساعدات ان كان لمناطق الفصائل وان
كان للمناطق الخاضعه للنظام هل تم رصد اي
مساعدات وصلت الى هذه المناطق من الجانب
الكردي
نعم هناك مئه شاحنه محمله بالوقود
اتجهت من مدينه منبج الخاضعه للسيطره
الاداره الذاتيه
باتجاه مدينه حلب هذه الشاحنات فعلا بدات
بالوصول الى مدينه حلب محمله بوقود
التدفئه والبنزين يعني هذه المواد مطلوبه
خاصه في مدينه حلب التي تعاني من شح في
مثل
المحروقات وايضا من الوقود لتشغيل
السيارات يوم غد سيكون هناك شاحنه اخرى
محمله بهذه المره بالمواد الغذائيه
المره الاولى
في في علاقات الخصمين يعني المعارضه
السوريه المسلحه
والاكراد هذه الشاحنه ستتجه الى المناطق
المنكوبه شمال غرب البلاد الواقعه تحت
السيطره فصال المعارضه طبعا هذه الشاحنه
كانت
جاهزه منذ يوم امس كان الاكراد يتهمون
يعني تركيا باعاقه دخولها لكن يبدو ان
المرافقات قد تمت وهذه الشاحنه ستتحرك يوم
امس باتجاه مناطق المعارضه في شمال غرب
البلاد وهذه يعني
لفته تؤكد بان يعني العلاقات الانسانيه
اهم من يعني من يعني العلاقات المتوتره
بين الخصوم في سوريا يعني على نفس شاكل
عندما دخل وفد مصري من مناطق النظام الى
مناطق المعارضه يعني سبب ذلك نوع من
الارتياح بين السكان واعطى يعني جرعه
معنويه اضافيه لفرق الدفاع المدني العامله
في ريف حلب وادلب لاستكمال اعمال الاغاثه
والازاحه الانقاض وبالتالي
نحن نتحدث عن عن تقدم الانسانيه على
العامل السياسي وعلى يعني التوترات
السياسيه والظروف السياسيه
يعني بمناطق عده ليس هناك اي تقديرات
رسميه وخصوصا بالمناطق السوريه بسبب الحرب
بسبب كل الوضع الحاصل هناك ولكن هل هناك
اي تقديرات لفرق الاوقات لما رصدتم
بالشارع حول اعداد التي ما زالت مفقوده او
حول الاعداد التي تم انقاذها
يعني حاليا على مستوى عموم سوريا تم
انتشال 453 شخص من تحت الانقاض احياء تم
توجيههم الى
المستشفيات سواء في اللاذقيه او طرطوس او
جبله او في حلب مركز المدينه اوريفها
وايضا في ادلب واريافها هذا العدد جيد
نوعا ما لكن يعني البحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاب مستمر في جبله يعني اوشكت عمليات
ازاله الانقاذ على الانتهاء مثلما حصل في
حماه انتهت الاعمال الاعمال ازاحه الركام
والبحث عن ناجين انتهى بشكل كامل على
جمعه لو سمحت ابقى معي ساعود اليك لنقل
الصوره من القامشلي ولكن سينضم الينا الان
من مدينه الدانه في ريف ادلب الصحافي محمد
الاشقر طبعا يعني حتى اليوم استطعنا حتى
هذه الساعه استطعنا ان نصل الى هناك الى
ريف ادلب لنقل هذه الصوره لمشاهده العربيه
محمد يعني الصوره بالاجمال كيف هو الواقع
على الارض بعد هذه الكارثه الانسانيه ماذا
عن عمليات الاغاثه وما الاحتياجات
الموجوده في المنطقه
نعم يعني نحن الان تحديدا في منطقه بسنيا
التابعه لمدينه حارم في ادلب طبعا هذه
المنطقه هي احدى المناطق التي تعرضت
للكارثه
المدمره نتيجه الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
المنطقه طبعا انتهت فرق الانقاذ مؤخرا من
انتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاض من هذه
المنطقه ولكن الى حد هذه اللحظه لا تزال
بعض الفرق موجوده تحسبا لاي لاي ابلاغ عن
وجود اي ضحايا تحت الانقاض طبعا هنا في
هذه المنطقه الحي مدمر بالكامل لا توجد
احصائيه دقيقه حتى هذه اللحظه حول الاعداد
الضحايا الحي مدمر ولكن كيف كيف يعني ما
قلت هل يعني ان عمليات البحث توقفت وهم
سيعيدون يعني يكملوا عمليات البحث فور
التاكد من وجود ناجين
نعم في هذه المنطقه في منطقه بثانيه توقفت
عمليات انتشال الضحايا من تحت الانقاض بعد
التاكد من جميع من عدم وجود ضحايا تحت
الانقاض ولكن تحسبا لاي بلاغ من اهالي
المنطقه حول فقدان احد زويهم بقيت احدى
الفرق موجوده هنا مع استكمال عمليات
الانقاذ في جميع المناطق الاخرى نحن نتحدث
عن عده مناطق تستمر لحد هذه اللحظه حتى
هذه الساعه عمليات الانقاص قبل قليل تمكنت
فرق الانقاذ من اخراج طفله صغيره في مدينه
ارمناز ايضا في مدينه عزمارين في ريف ادلب
تستمر عمليات البحث عن ناجين تحت الانقاض
ايضا في مدينه سلقين السوريه في مدينه
جنديرس المنكوبه في ريف مدينه عفرين ايضا
تستمر عمليات
محمد محمد عن الفرق الفرق جميعها هنا التي
تنقل لنا الصوره منها يعني واضح بالصوره
ان لا كهرباء وهو واقع المنطقه حتى قبل
الزلزال واليوم تازم مع الزلزال كيف تتم
عمليه البحث وعمليه يعني
البحث عن ناجين بهذه المنطقه مع عدم وجود
كهرباء مع ظروف طبيعيه صعبه
نعم يعني هنا فرق الانقاذ تعمل على بمعدات
بدائيه وسط غياب للتجهيزات اللازمه طبعا
يتم تزويد المنطقه في مناطق البحث عن
ناجين عن طريق مولدات الكهرباء عمليات
البحث عن انقاذ هي تتم بابسط الامكانيات
بمعدات بسيطه وهو الامر الذي فاقم الازمه
الازمه وجعل من هذه الكارثه الكبرى كارثه
اكبر كارثه انسانيه بحق
الجميع نظرا لعدم دخول اي مساعدات او اي
تجهيزات قد تساعد فرق الانقاذ التي تنتشر
في في المناطق المتضرره نحن نتحدث عن اكثر
من 56 منطقه تضررت في شمال غرب سوريا هناك
مناطق منكوبه بشكل كامل يعني الفرق
التطرق الانقاذ التابعه للدفاع المدني
الشبان المتطوعون ايضا الذين يساهمون في
عمليه الانقاذ الاهالي هؤلاء جميعهم
يعانون بسبب غياب المعدات المتطوره غياب
الاجهزه اللازمه والمجهزه للتعامل عن
الاجهزه عن النقص عن كل ما تعنيه المنطقه
هناك هل رصد دخول مساعدات طبيه مساعدات
اغاثيه مساعدات على اي مستوى الى هذه
المنطقه او فرق انقاص طبعا
نعم طبعا الى حد هذه اللحظه لم يدخل اي
مساعدات الى الداخل السوري اي اجهزه لم
تدخل الى الداخل السوري طبعا سبق والنفت
اداره معبر باب الهوى ببيان رسمي
ظهر هذا اليوم نفذ فيه الدخول اي اي
مساعدات او اي تجهيزات الى هذه المنطقه
طبعا عمليات البحث تتم بالاجهزه المتاحه
والموجوده هنا عمليات المساعده الانسانيه
وتقديم الدعم الغذائي والمياه تتم من خلال
عمليات التكافل الاجتماعي الموجوده هنا من
خلال عمليه التكافل الشعبي الموجوده هنا
من خلال مستودعات بعض المنظمات الانسانيه
الموجوده هنا بالاصل ولكن يعني الجميع
يعمل
باعلى طاقاته ولكن حجم الكارثه الكبرى
يفوق الطاقات المتاحه هنا نحن نتحدث عن
دعيني ان اسلط الضوء الى ان الد المدني
منظمه الدفاع المدني قد قد رفعت جاهزيتها
منذ اول ساعات حدوث هذه هذا الزلزال ولكن
يعني هم لا يملكون الاجهزه المتطوره التي
تساعدهم على على التسريع عمليه انتشال
الضحايا والجرحى من تحت الانقاض يعني في
الحقيقه نحن نتحدث هنا عن اي عن عن كل
ساعه تتاخر فيها المساعدات الدوليه عن
الداخل السوري نخسر فيها العديد من
الارواح مئات
الى ان اضيف للتعبير عن واقع الماساوي
لهذه المنطقه مشاهدينا يعني واقع انساني
صعب واقع حتى لوجستي صعب صحي على كل الصعب
وايضا يعني حتى وصلنا الى هذه المنطقه
كفريق عربيه اضطرينا ان نستعمل الاقمار
الاصطناعيه عبر الانترنت بسبب عدم وجود اي
يعني من
القناه التي ممكن ان تنقل الصوره من هناك
هذا الواقع واقع صعب جدا واقع انساني لا
يمكن
التغافل عنه وطبعا كما قال الزميل محمد
يجب يعني ان يتصل هذه الصرخه الى كل
المجتمع الدولي محمد على كل حال سنعود
اليك وننقل الصوره مجددا من هناك شكرا لك
الصحافه محمد الاشقر من الدانه في ريف
ادلب
سامحني
يعني في شيء كذا ولا
الصبر يا رب الصبر بس والله بتوجع كتير لا
تحرك ايدك لا تحرك ايدك ما عم بقدر احاول
تسحبك كثير
كثير بتوجعني
تركيا وسوريا عبثا كما يشاء بالممتلكات
والارواح وترك خلفه حطاما مكدسا لكن
الاكثر من ذلك ترك جروحا غائره من الالم
لكل من عاش هذا الكابوس الحقيقي ارقام
الوفيات مفاتيح تتزايد وحجم الخراب
والدمار يتسع شيئا فشيئا لكن ماذا عن حجم
الالم الذي لا يقاس بالارقام والاحصائيات
يومان فقط على مرور الزلزال كانا كافيين
لرصد مئات المشاهد المؤلمه والقصص الحزينه
التي ستبقى محفوره في الذاكره الاطفال
لوحدهم يحتلوا المساحه الاكبر من الحزن في
هذه الماساه فهل هناك اكثر حزنا من ان
تفقد طفله كل افراد عائلتها خلال 60 ثانيه
فقط او ان تحرم رضيعه حديثه الولاده من
دفء حضن امها التي رحلت تحت الانقاض كل من
عاشوا الكارثه شربوا من نفس الكاس المره
وان اختلفت مالاتهم النجاه لا تعفي من
الالم فهناك من اتعبه ترق سماع خبر عن
مصير اهله العالقين
اما اخرون فلم يجدوا سوى سيارتهم العتيقه
للاحتماء من البرد بعدما لم يعد لهم ماوى
بينما التحف ناجون العراء بعدما انهارت
اسقف كانت تقيهم برد الشتاء القارص حتى
الفرحه بالنجاه كانت مؤلمه مع هول الصدمه
كثيرون لم يجدوا سوى الدموع والصراخ
للتعبير عنها بل حتى هناك من لم يسعد حقا
بنجاته وكيف يفعل وقد سرق زلزال اعزاء ما
لديه
وسام الذهبي العربيه
اعد مشاهدينا مجددا الى القامشلي ومراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش جمعه يعني كنا نتحدث عن
المساعدات التي وصلت الى هناك من الجانب
الكردي
يعني بوجودك هناك على الارض ما المطلوب ما
العوائق اللوجستيه التي تعيق عمليات
الانقاذ كيف تتم هذه العمليات خصوصا بفتره
الليل مع ظروف مناخيه صعبه ومع امكانات
ضئيله
يعني الليله مختلفه عن الليلتين الماضيتين
في جميع المناطق فرق الانقاذ لم يتباطى
عملها وانما العمل يتم بوتيره متسارعه رغم
يعني الاعياء ورغم ظروف الليل والبرد
الجليله بالذات لا توجد امطار ولا توجد في
الوجود وبالتالي حتى يعني خلال النهار كان
الجو جيدا وهو ما ساعد ايضا فراغ الانقاذ
للعمل بشكل افضل يعني هذه الفرق وصلت الى
خداعه تامه بان
لانها يعني وصلت الى الساعات الاخيره من
حيث قدرتها على الوصول الى فعلا الفرص
تتضاءلت امام العالقين تحتها الانقاذ
بالبقاء على قيد الحياه نحن نتحدث الان عن
يعني حوالي 70 ساعه من البقاء في مناطق
مظلمه اناس اكيد مصابون يعانون من البرد
من الجوع من العطش وبالتالي الاستمرار تحت
الركام يبدو صعب جدا بالنسبه للعلاقين
وبالتالي هذه القضيه تتفهمها فرق الانقاذ
لذلك لم تتماطم يعني وتيره العمل بل
تتسارع في سباق مع الزمن للوصول الى اكبر
قدر ممكن من الناجين في جميع المناطق
المنكوبه التي يتركز عليها الضوء في هذه
الاوقات اللازمه في الهدفيه هناك فريق من
يعني فريق من الاختصاصيين خاصه قد وايضا
فريق من الغرب من الجزائر ومن ليبيا
ومشاركه من قوات الجيش الروسي في اللا
بينما يعني في المناطق الاخرى المناطق
خاطئه لسيطره المعارضه هناك
يستمر الاعتماد على الدفاع الذاتي
والمتطوعين الشباب اضافه الى فريق مصري
صغير يساعد في اعمال البحث عن الناجين في
مدينه في بلده
جنديرس شكرا لك مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش
على هذه الرساله من القامشلي
فقد رجل سوري خمسه وعشرين فردا من عائلته
في يوم واحد جراء الزلزال المدمر الذي
شهدته البلاد قبل يومين
[موسيقى]
هذا حفيد الثاني الله يرحمه
انا فاقد بنتي ولاده يعني
وبيت حمايه عمي ابو مجدي
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اسمحوا لي ان اشير الى هذا
العاجل الذي ورد الان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه تقول بان التبرعات حمله اغاثه
متضرري الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا تتجاوز 70
مليون ريال اذا كانت هذه التبرعات التي
جمعت حتى الساعه بعد الاعلان عن المبادره
السعوديه والحمل الشعبيه الواسعه للتضامن
مع الشعبين السوري والتركي في هذا المصاب
الاليم وفي هذه الكارثه التي حلت على
البلتين
من سرمدا بشمال سوريا ينضم الينا احمد
يزجي عضو مجلس مجلس اداره الدفاع المدني
السوري
واستاذ احمد يعني اذا امكن التحدث عن
ارقام تقديريه او يعني عن عدد النساء
والاطفال الذي تم انقاذهم حتى الساعه
والذين ما زالوا مفقودين ايضا حد الساعه
للاسف انا هاي الارقام اللي ممكن انا
اتداول حاليا هي ارقام متغيره خلال دقائق
فالرقم خلال هذه دقيقه يشير الى 1640 سفير
بالاضافه الى 2800 جريح تم توثيقهم من قبل
الفرق الدفاع المدني الذي تعمل الى حد هذه
اللحظه على افراد العالقين من تحت الانقاذ
منذ حوادث تقريبا ساعه
اخرجنا طفل على قيد الحياه في منطقه
عزمارين
على امل ان يكون هناك ان يكون هناك عده
نادين
موجودين تحت الانف ويكونوا على قيد الحياه
نعمل على هذا الامل ونعيش على هذا الامل
رغم الامكانيات المتوفره بين يدينا رغم
بروزه الطقس الشديد التي وصلت الان الى
الصفر وفي بعد منتصف الليل تصل الى مادون
الصفر نعمل على هذا الامل ان يكون هناك
نادين تحت الان
استاذ احمد بظل الامكانات التي يعني
الموجوده لديكم هناك بظل
الظروف بظل النقص على كافه المستويات هل
بدات تتضاءل الامال بوجود ناجين تحت
الانقاض
كلما تقدم لنا ساعه كلما تضاءلت الامل في
اخراج العالقين من تحت الانقاذ بالامس
ناشدنا جميع الدول ان يتم الاستعجال في
ارسال المعدات الخاصه في عمليات البحث
والانقاذ لكي نتمكن من اخراج اكبر عدد من
الناديين ولكن كلما تقدمت ساعه كلما
كان هناك
مفقودين اكثر للاسف نقول للاسف ان تاخير
دخول هذه المساعدات التي تساعد على انتشال
العالقين والتي تساعد فرق الدفاع المدني
التي اعتمدت على امكانياتها واعتمدت على
الجهات المدنيه والمحليه
والفرق التطوعيه
نتامل كانت تساعد اكثر ولكن تاخير دخولها
هكذا مساعدات
العمل في خروج
حديثك عن عن يعني عن ان الوقت اليوم
السباق مع الوقت اصبح حرج بعدما تاخرت
المساعدات ما تم يعني انتشاله بالساعات
الماضيه هل نتحدث عن جثث فقط ام ان هناك
بعض الاحياء الذين ما زلتم تستطيعون
انقاذهم لان طبعا هذا مؤشر على ساعه
المقبله
انا كما اسلفت سابقا انه خلال تقريبا
حوالي ساعه واخرجنا على قيد الحياه يعني
هناك امل ان يكون اشخاص على قيد الحياه
نعيش على هذا
المعدات كانت ستساعد كثيرا هذه المساعدات
كانت تساعد كثيرا في اخراج عدد اكبر من
المدنيين الذين هم على قيد الحياه ولكن
كلما تاخرت ساعه كلما ازداد رقم الوفيات
ونقص عدد الاصابات للاسف نقولها للاسف
لاننا
كنا على امل ان تكون هذه المساعدات تكون
في اقرب وقت ممكن ولكنها كانت عباره عن
وعود ولكن هذه الوعود كانت
نتمنى ان كانت تترجم بسرعه قسوه الى الان
تبقى وعود الى الان يوجد في العالمين تحت
الانقاب الى الان يوجد درجات حراره منخفضه
جدا يعيش اناس تحت هذه الانقاذ على امل
انقاذهم من قبل الفرق الدفاع المدني ولكن
للاسف نعمل بكل بكامل طاقاتنا نواصل الليل
بالنهار نواصل الوقت كامل لعمليات الافراد
عايشين على امل متقاتلين جميعا
ما يفيد الفرق دفاع المدني دخول المساعدات
بعد
او خمسه ايام
كمعدات استاذ احمد يعني الزملاء كانوا
يتحدثوا عن حوالي 30% من المباني المتضر
او المباني التي دمرت بالكامل تم انتشال
من هم بالساعات الماضيه وتفتيشها بحسب
الدفاع المدني هل نتحدث عن اقل او اكثر
ممكن تم توثيق
من قريه الدفاع المدني حوالي 360 مبنى هدم
بشكل كامل
بالاضافه لاكثر من 1100 مبنى تهدم بشكل
جزئي بالاضافه الى الاف المباني التي
تعرضت للصدع ان قلت الاف فهذا رقم يعني
قليل المباني سابقا كما يعلم الجميع انها
كانت عرضه لقصف من قبل الطيران الروسي
والسوري على هذه المنطقه ما طاقم الوضع هو
هذا الزلزال الذي ادى الى انهيارات عديده
في المباني ما ايضا طاقم في الوضع ايضا هي
الهزات الارتداديه التي رافقت هذا الزلزال
وثقت فراخنا خلال
اليومين الماضيين الى حد هذه اللحظه
تهدم ست مباني بشكل كامل من جراء
الارتداديه
عن طريق ايضا عملنا بالاضافه ما يؤخر ايضا
في اعمالنا هي بتلك الهزات الارتداديه
التي ممكن ان يكون المبنى المجاور للمبنى
الذي نعمل فيه يؤدي الى انهيار بشكل كامل
ويؤذي الفريق ولكن
يعمل تعمل جميع الفرق على امل
ان يكون هناك اشخاص على قيد الحياه غير
مباليين بهذه بهكذا امور بتسبب الطبيعه
الجغرافيه للدمار التي مشدد على اغلب
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الارتداد الدمار كان
كبير جدا
شكرا اليك استاذ احمد يازجي وايضا يعني
هذه الصرخه التي يجب ان تصل للعالم اجمع
لمساعده الشعب السوري في المناطق التي لم
تصلها المساعدات حتى اللحظه نحن نتحدث عن
مناطق باكمله لم تصلها مساعدات انسانيه
حتى اللحظه شكرا لك عضو مجلس اداره الدفاع
المدني السوري على هذه المداخله
[موسيقى]